So, it goes back, according to Islamic
teaching, number the caliphs,
Christians, but it was not sanctioned.
Listen, if you look at, let's say the
1800s, to really underscore the
the non-Islamic world, they're at war.
Now,
even though it's perpetual, and you can
talk about whatever the topic may be,
>> [music]
>> there's not some operation, because if
it's been around 10 years, and they
can't I get that part. But even
it was founded right around around
Welcome back to Politics by Faith, our
special, The Rise of Islam. No one
better, more important to talk to than
Raymond Ibrahim.
These are the three books I have as his.
Sword and the Scimitar,
Defenders of the West, and most
recently,
The Two Swords of Christ. Working
through all of them, and please check
out his YouTube as well. Raymond Ibrahim
HW. Just search for it, you'll find it.
Raymond, how do you do, sir?
Good, Mike. Thanks for having me again.
Good to be with you. I'm grateful for
you. Why is it important for people to
read about and know about the Crusades
in the year 2026?
Because they're remarkably
appropriate and applicable to much of
what's happening today.
Um
I'm always fond of quoting the biblical
verse in Ecclesiastes, there's nothing
new under the sun, and I often find that
is in fact the case, especially when it
comes to these big themes, big ideas,
big historical, cataclysmic,
uh developments that we see, they often
have precedents. And so, I think the
importance of the Crusade today is for
those who don't know,
Western civilization in general,
especially the Christian element, has
been at war
with Islam for since its very beginning.
Most people are unaware that Islam is
literally spread over and conquered the
vast majority of what was what once
formed the Christian world. And I speak,
of course, of North Africa, from Egypt
all the way to Morocco, and all of the
entire Middle East, all the countries
that we know today. Syria, Israel, Iraq,
Palestinian territories, Jordan,
Lebanon, and of course, Asia Minor, what
we call Turkey.
That was the heart and the center of the
Christian world in the 7th century.
You know, there's only there's five
historic Christian ecclesiastical sees.
The one that we recognize and that
wasn't conquered is Rome. The other four
were conquered, and they were equally as
important, and they would be Alexandria,
Antioch, Jerusalem, and later
Constantinople. And so,
when I look at the conflicts between
Muslims and Christians, or Westerners
and Muslims, or anyone
and Muslims, Israelis, you know, the the
the Arab-Israeli or Iranian-Israeli
conflict, there's definitely precedents
for it, and there's reasons for it, and
they ultimately trace back to Islamic
teaching as as as taught by the prophet
of Islam, Muhammad, and as captured in
the Quran. These are core teachings
which set the Muslim world at odds
against the non-Muslim world. And that
was the case historically when Islam was
stronger and it conquered, as I said, so
much of the Christian world, and it also
went further east, conquered Indian
civilizations, went further into east,
and of course, later sub-Saharan Africa,
conquests there and the massive slave
trade.
Um so, to me, you know, I like I learn
from continuity and from patterns. So,
when you see, you mentioned my books,
one of them, Sword and the Scimitar,
especially focuses on just showing you
these patterns that continuously,
unwaveringly
have developed of conflict, always from
the Muslim side. That's the initiating
side, essentially. And today, the
problem is where whereas there is still
continuity from the Muslim worldview,
one that is hostile to the infidel,
seeks to subjugate, subvert, take over,
the West has completely forgotten all
about it as part of it the new identity.
And this is why the Crusades are
important, to go back to your initial
observation and question, because they
are a reminder of, no, it's not that
easy. You can't just, you know, snap
your fingers and say we're going to
start a new slate, no matter how much
you'd like to. You can mean that, but
Islam initiated hostilities. It's it's
it's in its creed, and therefore it is
still creating hostilities, whether it's
what's happening in the Middle East in
general, whether it's Muslim migrants
going into Europe, creating mass havoc,
and so forth. So, I do believe there are
much lessons to be learned from history.
What is the most important thing that we
need to know about the let's just call
it I mean, I guess theology, if you
will, or the teachings of Islam and the
Quran and and the faith?
That's a good question, because a lot of
people,
you know, [clears throat] go down rabbit
holes trying to find all the bad things
about Islam, and there is a lot. But for
me, I'm much more interested in
ascertaining those things that have a
negative impact on me as a non-Muslim.
And there, I've really looked into it
deeply and discussed it much, and it's
really three interrelated teachings and
doctrines.
The most popular of which is jihad, but
really the first one that comes before
jihad is what initiates all this. In
Arabic, it's called al-wala wal-bara,
>> [snorts]
>> which is an another doctrine found in
the Quran, which teaches Muslims to
always be loyal to fellow Muslims, and
to always have enmity, renunciation for
and up to hatred for every non-Muslim.
Literally, it teaches that. You can
check out Quran 60, sura 60A:4.
And that's what it says, you have a good
example in Abraham, the prophet Abraham,
who has now been appropriated
in the Quran as a different figure,
because he told his clansmen that he
hates them until they believe in Allah.
Okay, so that's that's become the
pattern. Now,
this, of course, is just another smart
way for a 7th century Arab, Muhammad, to
rearticulate tribalism, which was, of
course, rife in his day. Everyone was
part of a tribe and the tribalistic
mentality. So, he take that he took that
notion, but articulated it through a
theological paradigm. So, now it's not
my tribe versus your tribe, it's the
ummah, we the Muslims versus you the
kafir, the infidel. Okay, so that's the
first one. That Now, that one manifests
itself in the way you would expect, in
jihad, violence, armed struggle, holy
war, and conquest, and which I've
already touched on from a historical
point of view, and which is still
emanating today. And again, you know,
the word jihad means to strive. It
doesn't literally mean holy war as in
physical violence, though that has been
its primary been its primary
manifestation historically, but today
there's different forms of jihad which
the Islamic clerics have articulated,
and these would be jihad of the tongue,
jihad of the pen, jihad of the womb,
jihad of
the money, and all of these mean
basically jihad of propaganda, jihad of
deception, jihad of having overwhelming
Western nations with babies, that's the
jihad of the womb or demographic jihad.
Jihad of money is funding and
supporting, let's say, Islamic
terrorists, or even just Islamic
propaganda. Okay, so that's the jihad,
and then the final doctrine is what
happens to the conquered infidel.
Well, if he's not outright butchered, he
has to be subjugated and suppressed. He
can never live as an equal in an Islamic
polity. And this is why all throughout
the Islamic world today, non-Muslims, if
there are any, are really treated in a
very inhumane way. So, I believe those
are the three most important doctrines,
and as you can see, they're
interrelated, that every non-Muslim
should be cognizant of.
Something I've been
fascinated to read more about, and you
just mentioned with Abraham, is how
Muhammad, who was illiterate, took
different aspects of different religions
that were around there, right? Cuz he
was raised his parents died and and his
grandpa died, and he was raised by his
uncle, right? Who was a traveler or a
tradesman. So, he like heard all these
different things and kind of cobbled
them all together. And one of them was
Jesus. And I've heard a Muslim told me,
Oh, and and Tucker Carlson said this the
other day, hey, Muslims believe in
Jesus. We love Jesus.
And it's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's
it's a very different Jesus. Can you
speak to that?
Absolutely. This is, of course, one of
the strategies that apologists for Islam
and Muslims themselves engage in, which
is
they'll tell you things like, look, we
we actually believe in what you believe
in. They'll say things like, we believe
in Jesus' virgin birth, and that he was
sinless and perfect, and he he he
performed miracles, and he's also coming
in the end days. All of which is true.
The the Quran does teach that. But more
importantly, especially from a Christian
point of view, is that it also teaches
that
it actually contradicts the more core
doctrines, which, of course, are the
divine the divinity of Christ as the son
of God, that he was crucified, that he
died, and that he was resurrected.
Those, of course, which were recently
captured in Easter, are the key
doctrines of what it is to be a
Christian, lesser so
Christmas. So, Islam completely condemns
those. It condemns the Trinity. Again,
it condemns it calls infidels, which is
a horrible thing to say, kafir, is is he
who says Jesus is the son of God or who
believes in the Trinity, and they should
be waged war against. Okay, this is
Quran 9:29, which says basically wage
war against the people of the book,
which would be Christians and Jews,
until, like I said, they either convert
or pay tribute and live suppressed
in keeping with that third doctrine.
[snorts] But that,
you know, more broadly speaking, that's
what the Quran does, because it's the
latecomer, it tried to appropriate the
um
the the the important figures of
antiquity, from Adam and Eve all the way
to Jesus. And so, it does it pays lip
service to them, but then it really
disfigures them. And so, Jesus, for
example, in the end times, Isa, as he's
known, what he's going to do when he
comes back is he's in in the end times,
he's going to come and break the cross,
kill all the pigs, and abolish jizya.
The jizya is what, if you're a Christian
or a Jew, you pay tribute, you live in
submission under Islamic rule. So, by
abolishing it, it means now you can no
longer be a Christian or a Jew. You
accept the sword or you
or you convert to Islam. So, clearly not
the same Jesus. So, anyone who says
Muslims love Jesus, well, yeah, I
believe they leave they love Isa. And
Isa is something of a doppelganger of
Jesus.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. What do you make
of the Pope's recent comments? I got I
got one here. He said, "Communion
between Christians and Muslims take
shape under the mantle of Our Lady of
Africa. Here in Algeria, the material of
the maternal love of Lady Maryam, who
they say is like a princess there,
gathers everyone as children with their
rich diversity and our shared aspiration
for dignity, love, justice, and peace.
In a world where division and war sow
pain and death, living in unity and
peace is a compelling sign."
What do you make of the Pope's embrace
of Muslims?
Well, this Pope, um, I I I'm not too
familiar with what you just said, but
basically the gist of this Pope is not
unlike the previous Pope, Pope Francis,
which seems they're they they seem eager
to just show the world that they're
peacemakers, they love everyone, which
in my eyes makes it really uh waters
down what they do represent. If you're
the Pope of the this religion,
Catholicism, and you say things which
essentially make it sound like
Catholicism is not the true way. And I'm
not Catholic, by the way, okay? So, but
I'm I'm looking at it from a Catholic
point of view. And if you make it sound
that, "Oh, every religion, Islam is just
as well, and it's all about peace and
love." Obviously, Christianity has a lot
of room for peace and love. I'm not
arguing that, but there's also a you
know, a time where you make a stand for
the truth. And that's what I don't see
in so many of these modern Popes. At
least the last one would have been
Benedict who did take something of a
stand. Um, the last two just seem, if if
what I'm hearing is correct, that
they're just more interested in saying
the sorts of things that will make them
popular uh amongst, you know, the world
because they're being so ecumenical and
open, and less in actually standing for
the faith, which is their number one job
as the shepherds, in this case, of the
Catholic Church.
60 seconds. What is one story of one of
the Crusaders, one of the heroes that
you talk about that you find at this
moment very inspiring that you want
people to learn more about in uh
Defenders of the West. That's the one
I'm working through right now.
Uh, well, you know what? You ask me a
question like that, I'm just going to
think chronologically, so it's going to
be the first one, chapter one, Godfrey
of Bouillon in the first Crusade. And
he's a very inspiring man. He He was a
first Crusader. He sold everything, gave
away much of his lands, went through so
much suffering, almost died, was
attacked by a bear uh in Anatolia,
almost died then. Um, was a stalwart
warrior, was known for splitting Muslims
in half with a sword thrust. So, you
know, very uh legendary stuff. And then
he was elected as the first king of
Jerusalem after the conquest of
Jerusalem, or reconquest in 1099. But he
famously said, when they gave him a
crown, that I will not wear a crown of
gold where my savior wore a crown of
thorns. So, that is the sort of men who
litter the the pages of Defenders of the
West, which is to say who litter the
pages of history. And um, I think it's
time for Christians to recapture that
sort of worldview and
um, stamina.
Hm. I hate that I've gone my whole life
without having heard these stories.
Um, but I'm grateful for you that I know
them and now my kids know them. They've
heard these names, they've heard these
stories.
Uh, they've they've heard two They've
already rolling their eyes at the story
of uh the first siege in Jerusalem when
they got the uh the the boat came with
all the siege equipment and they had to
hike 40 miles to get the boat and bring
all the siege equipment to the walls.
They've heard that story a lot as they
complain about being hot or thirsty or
something like that. I was like, "Don't
complain. Let me tell you about the
first Crusade." So, I'm grateful that
they will know these stories as well,
Mr. Ibrahim. I read them out of order,
so Sword of the Sultana, then Defenders
of the West, then The Two Swords of
Christ. Hopefully, many more to come,
Mr. Ibrahim. Grateful for you and your
time. Thank you, sir.
Thanks very much, Mike. Happy to be with
you again. Bring back the
fire.
Bring back the
in the
righteous name.